love him or hate him Napoleon is a
figure probably unrivaled in modern
history I'm going to take you some
snapshot iconic moments in some of his
battles T long
1793 we're down here on the
Mediterranean coast of
France here we have the young Napoleon
24 years old full of energy full of zeal
for the Revolution and that Revolution
is in danger the city of tou long has
been occupied by French royalists the
young Napoleon is given the task of
leading an assault on this important
Fort which he does the French fire at
the Fortress and then they storm it
using infantry and ladders and Napoleon
himself leads the attack he stabbed in
the thigh by a British soldier with a
baronet but the attack succeeds and the
British are pushed
out Battle of the pyramids
1798 we're now way down south on the map
on the Southern Shores of the
Mediterranean in Egypt here we're going
to be looking at Napoleon experimenting
with a new formation the divisional
square and looking at his sense of
Destiny actually the battle took place
some 9 miles away from the pyramids but
what's wrong with a bit of artistic
license he has captured the city of
Alexandria but he's now faced with a
vast medieval infantry and Cavalry of
the mamalukes the soldiers of the
Ottoman Turks who rule Egypt he brings
on what was called the divisional Square
each division had three brigades and
each Brigade was formed into a square of
infantry guns at each corner and Cavalry
in the middle now squares were used
throughout European Warfare but they Ed
for a very particular purpose just to
repel Cavalry so he's adapting the
square making it a combined arms
formation and using it offensively not
defensively he moves South in this
formation towards the enemy supported by
the gunfire of his ships the mamalukes
attack and Superior French Firepower
murders them they retreat some of them
try to cross the Nile and are drowned
and the French are left in possession of
the field alitz
1805 we are here in what's now the Czech
Republic here we're going to look at
Napoleon prepared to take risks that
could be fatal but also as a master of
deception laring his enemies into a trap
from which they can't
escape this is a portrayal of an
incident which actually happened it's
reported that 150 guns were lost and a
lot of men were drowned two or 3 Days
Later Napoleon ordered the ponds to be
drained and although 150 horses were
found only two human bodies were
reported Napoleon has instituted the
core system each core is a combination
of artillery infantry Cavalry engineers
and light troops it's all arms it allows
him to expand the Army to something
bigger than has been seen in Europe
since ancient times He makes himself
appear weak in the South here on his
right flank because what he wants to do
is make the enemy launch a flanking
attack bring them down off the pratts
and Heights to attack him and envelop
him in the South will be able to take
these attackers in the flank and deal
with them Napoleon himself will then be
able to unleash the decisive Act of the
battle a central attack on the enemy
position up here on the pratts and
Heights the austrians play right into
his hands and he turns to Marshall salt
the commander of the fourth core who's
going to lead the attack and says to
salt
one sharp jab and the war is over Lutsen
spring of
1813 we are at Lutsen which is in the
southern part of Germany here we're
going to be looking at Napoleon making
and implementing decisions far more
rapidly than his opponents can do and
we're going to see him inspiring and
leading the troops personally and
bringing that magnetism to bear on the
battlefield what Lutsen gives us is a
glimpse of Napoleon's powers of analysis
and decision- making Napoleon after all
his years in the field is now a master
of this what unfolds at Lutsen well it's
what's called a meeting engagement and a
meeting engagement occurs when two
bodies of troops are moving towards each
other but they don't know very much
about each other and unexpectedly they
Collide and victory will go to the side
that most speedily and most effectively
takes advantage of the chaos Napoleon
himself rides to the sound of the guns
morale is pretty shaky but his
appearance Works magic the troops see
him and somehow they know that
everything will be okay and those cries
so dreaded by his enemies on the
battlefield begin to rise Viv lomper not
only does he Inspire the troops but he
actually takes charge of them leads them
to the Counterattack exposing himself to
enemy fire and it's said that this is
the day of his career more than any
other when he was in most danger of
being killed waterl 18
15 we are at watero in what's now
Belgium and it's just to the south of
Brussels here's Napoleon at the end of
his career he's older he's tired he's
suffering the Pains of duodenal cancer
he nearly carries the day but in the end
he's caught in his own
trap well here we've got some great
footage of the use of squares we talked
about squares earlier in Egypt and
here's the defensive use of squares by
the British Army against that massed
Cavalry Ridley Scots used enough people
in it to give you the sense of being
there which too many TV programs uh just
don't do the powers of Europe have
declared war not on France but on him
and they're closing in Napoleon
organizes a proper combined arms attack
which captures the farm of leant it
means that the French can bring their
artillery right up close blast a hole in
the British Center and then plow through
it but at this critical moment the
prussians are appearing on the French
right Napoleon has to detach part of the
Guard core to stop them once the haa is
taken the critical moment has arrived
the guard weakened as it is is committed
it's stopped dead the prussians break
through on his right flank and
Napoleon is caught in his own trap of a
flanking
attack Napoleon leaves the field of
battle tries to Rally the army at Philip
Ville but is not able to do so it's the
end for
Napoleon he finishes his life as an
exile on the island of St
helina we've been focusing on Napoleon
and his prowess on the battlefield he
did however leave a considerable Legacy
he reshaped armies through his core
system and through his staff system that
have largely endured to the present day
to this day he is still an iconic figure
if that were not so then Ridley Scott
would not have invested as he has done
in making this
movie